[Music]
hi there I'm Seth Juarez and this is the
Microsoft research faculty summit 2017
where the theme is the edge of AI and
I've got a special guest to talk about a
really interesting project so let's talk
a little bit about the actual problem
that you're working on because I saw a
demo this and I was absolutely floored
by how amazing it was why don't you give
us a little background on what it is
yeah this does yeah sure so first you
know that the cancer is one of the like
biggest killers rights in the world and
the incidence of cancer just going up as
people get older in the world like more
and more people kept cancer eventually
so one of the few ways to treat cancer
is radiation therapy and about half of
cancer patients get radiation therapy
radiation therapy is about using a
special purpose-built machine that
delivers ionizing radiation to a
specific part of your body where the
tumor is so a patient body where the
tumor is with the intent to kill the
tumor cells or at least you know subside
their their growth and this radiation
therapy of the planning of this
treatment is powered by medical imaging
so what they do essentially take a scan
a CT scan or MRI scan and they need to
basically outline every every organ that
there is there to you know to tell the
Machine what exactly needs to be used to
be treated and I have a little video
here so you know if we kind of look at
it here's a radiation oncologist
planning a treatment of a patient so you
can see that basically it's a very
primitive tool you just draw outlines
right and then you switch to the next
slide and you draw another outline so
you know medical images multiple slices
taken one after another
let's give like 300 slices or 200 slices
it's a very manual very laborious
process and we built a tool that you
know helps save time that take this
process from you know between 30 and 40
minutes down to five and this is
interesting right because when you're
shooting this radiation at the tumor you
don't want to hit anything else because
it's doing harm to the tumors you don't
want to do harm to the other things
exactly exactly that's why you don't
only have to you know delineate the
tumor you also want to doing it all the
organs around the tumor and at the end
and have to delineate it like up to 30
20 30 different structures in one in one
image right then some of the structures
like tumor they're different between
patient but some of them are the same
right so in the end the variation
College ascends up countering like
hundreds of the same you know hip bones
that look exactly the same between
patients but they still have to do that
and that's 40 minutes of work for the
radiation oncologist is it the actual
doctor that's doing it yeah it depends
on the case right so brain brain tumors
they take them they might take longer
like prostate they're both so long so
some some are simpler in some centers
their radiation oncologist highly-paid
physicians doing that and some centers
they have like the same interest which
are people for whose job is to do this
yeah but yes it's an expensive expensive
thing to do and usually the physicians
could do that instead of you know using
the time that they might have used to
actually read the page I mean 40 minutes
of treating a patient is a lot different
than effectively doing Photoshop on tons
of slices of a of a diagram of what's
inside the body right so what does inner
eye actually do to help that and how
does AI help
yeah yeah so we basically our team there
is a team of researchers in our ms our
cambridge UK lab sure who works on
computer vision and image segmentation
problems for many many years they
contributed to Microsoft Kinect and
right now we are using same principles
to build machine learning models that
can actually detect they can actually
find those body parts for you in an
image right so this is our tool this is
the project that we're working on and it
looks like any other you know medical
imaging tools you you see all the
standard components are three cardinal
planes we have this 3d rendering here
but this has this neat little button
that says auto structure set and this is
something that none of the tools in the
market currently have and you can see
that allows you to select what kind of
image are we looking at and what kind of
structures are we looking at in this
image so right now I have a patient and
computer tomography scan of a patient
with a prostate cancer open here and
when I press the start button it kicks
off the you know the evaluation of our
machine learning model which has been
trained on a hundreds of images from
participating institutions and hospitals
that we that we work with it has seen a
lot of a lot of those contoured sets and
in just under a minute probably here you
have the pretty accurate segments
of a prostate cancer case right and this
is not 100% correct so some physicians
would you know would now look at that
and say that okay so I don't like how
this leather is coming out here so the
yellow portion here is whether right so
probably click the edit button and I
would kind of fix it up a little bit but
you know still rather than doing it from
scratch you're just fixing up the works
majority of work 90% is done by the by
the you've taken something that may have
taken 40 minutes to an hour down to like
maybe five or six minutes to make sure
that it's okay yeah yeah this is the
hope right and and again you're fixing
someone else's work as opposed to like
creating same thing over and over again
so this is pretty amazing and it looks
like you you're able to also map into
the 3d picture as well tell us about
what we're looking at here exactly this
is the 3d render this is another kind of
product that came out of our Amazon
Cambridge lab yeah but it kind of
renders the you know the data sets in
three dimensions and you can look at the
you can actually look at the organs
right and you can see how well it's kind
that what it's actually figured out from
now pictures yeah that's what I figured
out from the picture so you can see the
right hip bone for example here that was
contoured by the automated algorithm and
you know if you know much about Anatomy
you say that it's pretty much accurate
so let's talk about the AI that that was
involved in making this actually work
because it feels a little magical but I
want it like we're all this is the
faculty summit right we're talking about
research absolutely how did you how did
this happen you said you mention a
little bit about about sort of the the
AI that was happening at Cambridge like
the Kinect stuff did some of that was
some of that involved with this because
it feels like the same kind of problem
yeah yeah you know so the connect
project started way back when right in
the early 2000s I think and what they've
done for Kinect they were using machine
learning models to solve a image a
segmentation problem right so they were
using a three dimensional data right
they were using the flat image from the
Kinect camera plus using the depth
information from the depth sensor to
find body parts in the image right to
tell that this is a these voxels in this
image
probably belong to their left arm and
this is the right arm and they said they
had and this is the these are the legs
so now from in machine learning speak
this is a classification problem that
were on the classification algorithm on
each voxel so same guys who worked on
this so my boss Antonio community who is
a principal researcher on this project
here and contributed to connect so they
took this idea further right this idea
is based on the on the concept of
decision trees they you know the
algorithm has been improved
significantly and has been tuned to fit
this particular problem of medical image
segmentation but the core is kind of the
same so you have this decision tree
right and the idea of decision tree that
at each node you train a very simple
classifier that tries to maximize kind
of the purity of the classes right so
all the training points all the training
all the walks will get into one node and
then you try to figure out to split them
into parts so that you know the the
devoxx cells that probably belong to one
to one kind of type of type of data goes
to the left node and another goes to the
right node and that process happens over
and over and over and here down in the
tree you end up with you know having to
split between like voxel that more
likely belong to a bladder or works a
lot more likely belong to a prostate and
at the very end you have very few
classes that has helped kind of decision
so when I remembered I remember the
Kinect was certainly novel because I
mean here I understand what decision
trees are and usually I'm more about
well what's the feature selection than
to you now in the Kinect they actually
pick the point that you want to predict
and pick the same set of points around
it not just with the the actual image
but with the actual depth data and those
were the features is it similar in this
case yeah yeah so the feature selection
process here is somewhat similar to
connection connect would be used was
they were looking at the current voxel
and they were randomly sampling a few
points around this right in a 3d cube in
a 3d cube around this voxel so what
we're doing here we tried that and we
found right now I think we're using just
a full-fledged 3d convolutions we're
looking at all the voxel around them and
kind of assigning ways to them the trees
assigning ways to them and we've taken
this process a little bit further so as
opposed to doing this just based on the
voxel voxels around the current voxel we
also use cascades of decision trees
right and in reality the we use decision
for assuming it's right like 51 but the
output of one forest serves as an in
into another forest right so the forest
downstream looks at the voxels you know
the voxel intensities but also looks at
the predictions from the previous forest
so it know that you know this Vark so to
the left of it is something that looks
like a right femur to the ruler to the
right of something looks like a like a
left femur right and so probably this
fox is more likely to be a bladder
because it's between something that
looks like hips
so let's talk about this because this
feels very similar to maybe something
that would happen in a neural network
but more tree like is it similar
different yeah you can say so so you
know these days everybody talks about
deep learning right so what deep
learning really is you train multiple
layers of network and layers kind of do
different things a little bit but you
use the output of one layer is an input
into your another layer right and in the
end you end up with kind of layer that I
used something very very some users
high-level features as an input for
input to it right like at the beginning
you might have been looking at just
pixel voxel intensities and the layers
further to the end you're looking at
high level things like nose you know if
you're trying to classify human faces
like nose ears eyes or things like that
so really if something similar is
happening here we're just not not using
neural network using decision trees
which we reserved there's a multiple
yeah there are like cascades of those
decision forests so let's talk a little
bit about this about this this program
that you build is this it's just that
you use the word tomography did I get
that right is it tomography type program
so tomography is a method of imaging
human body right so dry like machines
that use certain physical kind of
phenomenons to phenomena to to get an
imaging of the human internal there are
several kinds of tomography there is
computed tomography there is magnetic
resonance tomography yeah so our our
algorithm right now for this prostate
scans worst worse than computed
tomography but really kind of the
underlying technique can work in any
kind of ID and that was the question
because what I was leading to is tell me
about the data set that you use or to
train this effectively because I'm
assuming that what was the size of your
data set for example and then what kind
of data because it looks like we focused
on prostate cancer will this work to
extrapolate other organs inside of the
body
yeah so the so actually a working of
data set was ended up
being more challenging and much more
interesting that we thought it would be
because there is so much variation and
how prostate cancer patients are imaged
between different institutions you would
think you know just take a computer
tomography everyone it looks like kind
of the same and go for it
well know right so one institution likes
to image patients with contrast inside
their bladder another institution
wouldn't plan something in there right
somebody else will do some additional
like contraptions that would you know
that would fixate like a pay patient in
one place so a lot of effort went into
generalizing between the different ways
how different institutions kind of image
their patients but the underlying
technique like I said it's a
classification problem for that looks at
individual voxels it doesn't really care
whether it's a you know computed
tomography or magnetic resonance
tomography or whether it's a functional
MRI or a PET scan right so it would look
at it work with any kind of a 3d image
data and moreover so that's one of the
benefits while the reasons why we're
using decision 3 is opposed to like
neural net it's it can use multiple
input layers because like for brain
cancer patients they took different they
say usually take different kinds of Amar
scans with different settings like
there's like t1 CAD with liked with
contrast injection then there is a flare
with a little hood and they will look at
different aspects that different you
know clinical characteristics of the
tumor and usually a physician looks at
multiple multiple of those scans so this
kind of algorithm can use multiple
channels actually it can it can look at
multiple kinds of images and it can kind
of predict based on that but what's
interesting is if you for example
trained it to look on three kinds of
from our scans but you only have one at
the time of scan it would still work
because of the kind of nature
so were you using were you using the
three different kinds of scans and the
reason I'm asking because this is super
interesting in terms of the data that
you are using in the algorithms are
using we're using all three of the scans
to do the training but because it had
all three scans it inferred well enough
to be able to just use one of them yeah
yeah so because the decision tree right
you if you if you don't have and it just
referred to so what I've just shown the
prostate case we only use one type of
scan well don't use this multi-layer but
this is something that has been done in
research but theoretically yeah
technique if you trained it on three
layers like three types of mr I only
have one
it'll just use the part of the tree that
you know this has to do with this one
and Mars one MRI right so all the other
branches of the tree just one do one we
used voxels one go there what if what if
you have one of these kinds of scans and
you don't for example because it looks
like you had a specific prostate set you
might have a set of other set what if
they just want to go in in color because
I remember like in Photoshop there's
this like magic wand tool could this to
like select the right area is there a
way to do that with this program as well
you get a mask yeah so this program we
wanted to build this program we didn't
want to billion on abstract kind of
research your tool they don't it does
one thing well which is not practical at
all right wanted to build something
practical and we built in a lot of more
conventional tools that people would use
I can show you here like a quick demo
for example this is a patient this is a
different patient so this is not a
prostate scan anymore this is a scan of
the for X so the of your chest part and
this is a patient with this patient has
been injected with contrast dye so you
can see this kind of huge one white spot
in the middle this is the aorta with
contrast injected in and let me try to
contour the aorta here so you can see
I'm using kind of a a very natural tool
this pen here pen and they just you know
draw a contour around this slice and
normally a you know the Eurasian
colleges would switch the next place and
every XY near every slice so I won't do
that I will just skip through skip over
a few hundred slices and go to the point
where a or two split so you know you can
see the two while your loves here but
trust me those are this is the place
where your two splits into left and
right femoral arteries so let me draw
the contour around those right and you
can see that right now the algorithm had
run and an interpolation you know our
own interpolation algorithm had run and
it has contour the aorta you can see
it's not like hundred percent precise it
captured some of the vertebrae here so I
can click there alright and I can use
again use my pen
to take this slice slice slice up and
I'll just delete all this vertebrae
artifacts and probably part of the
kidney that had wrapped here and just
now the algorithm which was again
developing our Cambridge lab a trendy
interpolation in three dimensions across
what like two hundred and eight slices
here and we have a pretty accurate
segmentation of the you know they main
blood vessel in this patient so we have
tools like that which allow the
physicians you know to do the entire
contouring workflow within a tool and
that's that's quite remarkable because
there may be a situation where there is
a type of cancer that hasn't been
trained on yeah where you can go ahead
and do this kind of technique inside of
these scans yeah yeah exactly and in the
end right we don't say that this
technology is supposed to replace kind
of the audition colleges and do all
their job so they're faster now yeah
it's a fast start and in many cases they
would want to contour more things that
you know we're here we have the seven
organs like leather femurs prostate but
probably they would count or another
like five or ten they would want to do a
several kind of settle volumes around
the tumor itself because they want to
treat a little bit larger reserve the
tumor and the actual tumor they don't
want to count or like in a portion of
the liver that gets into there something
like that and this is usually the same
machinery techniques from before but to
do extrapolation is that right now what
I was just talking about is that they
you know they would use the simpler
tools like the one that I've shown you
now that using did this interpolation to
contour the organs that machines that
machine learning had not ideally I see
right so the algorithm that we use
technically it's not machined or yeah I
feels like it'd be like a search of some
kind yeah yeah actually it's actually
it's solving the minimization problem so
in a sense it is machine learning but it
runs locally there is no like the strain
test phase is just optimized as kind of
the path between and that's I mean it's
pretty amazing because now you're taking
someone that's having obviously a very
bad time there they have cancer and
you're minimizing the amount of useless
work that a trained physician or someone
in the medical community has to do and
they can focus now on a care of the
actual pace yeah exactly this is the
this is the promise here because we
believe we call this assistive ai as
opposed to
you know AI it's kind of replace all
radiologists because right now there is
this kind of buzz in the special in
medical community that you know a is
coming is going to replace all
radiologists three units will go out of
a job so people are people are really
like apprehensive you know they they are
scared of this advent of AI and we think
that it doesn't have to be like that
because first humans are pretty good at
diagnosing right so right now there are
a lot of startups and a lot of companies
out there working on developing AI that
will kind of diagnose cancer based on
medical image well it might be useful
but really like a you know experienced
radiologist will diagnose cancer based
on medical imaging like in a few seconds
right don't need to really have AI for
that so this is amazing stuff just to
finish up what's next for a project you
know there are plenty of things that
this kind of technology can unlock it
there is this whole field of
quantitative radiology and surprisingly
this whole kind of medical imaging area
has been underserved by AI there is
there aren't really good tool that help
physicians become better and help them
spend more time with patients so you
know you can track tumor progression
over time you can just things like
adaptive radiation therapy where you
know an AI system would actually look at
how to more response to a radiation
treatment in real time between sessions
and would adjust the treatment based on
that as a pope because right now they
build one plan the one that I've shown
you and they use that plan pretty much
unchanged to multiple sessions of
therapy right and to more obviously
changes so you know a lot of things that
we can do to improve these so this is
amazing stuff and the thing I like about
it most is that we can do a lot with
computer vision we can match images and
we can sort images you know this is
probably one of the best applications of
computer vision that I've seen because I
mean it goes to the heart of our
humanity in curing cancer yeah thanks so
much for spending some time with
assignment thanks for having me thanks
so much for watching we will see you
next time take care
you
[Music]